in the cbs prime time drama all rise the
main character is a black woman who
serves as a judge
in a california courtroom it is not a
common sight
including right here in nevada tonight
orkomana introduces us to two local
african-american judges
who talk about their unique experiences
behind the bench and how they're
encouraging the next generation
the african-american female perspective
was definitely missing before me
a vital viewpoint in nevada's legal
landscape judge tierra jones is the
first black woman to be appointed to the
district court bench in the entire state
that happened back in 2017 i'm just so
honored to be a part of you know
starting that trend
jones tells me her diversity is a
driving force in her decision making
especially in life-changing criminal
cases
this as african-americans continue to be
disproportionately incarcerated
you understand that they may have faced
some disadvantages starting out
just because of the color of their skin
and it's something that
it definitely makes you think about
because it's an experience that you have
had
jones previously worked as a public
defender and as a prosecutor she says
those career choices which allowed her
to see both sides of the system
help keep her objective it's very very
important for you to be the neutral man
you to be the neutral magistrate because
that is your job and that's what you are
here to do
african-americans only make up a handful
of judges in nevada courtrooms judge
timothy williams was appointed nearly 15
years ago to the district court bench
he says he's noticed that over the years
getting more people of color like him
in this field is a slow but steady
process we want to have a community that
hopefully
a bench that will hopefully reflect the
community but just as important too
you want to have qualified district
court judges
that's what you want to have and it just
takes time
part of that process is paving a path to
the future jones does this through
various mentorship roles
it's become like a personal
responsibility of mine
so that young women and young
african-american women can see
she looks like me and she did this so
there's nothing stopping me from being
able to do this
paying it forward in an effort to create
change
orco mana 8 news now